شغفها للترحال والتعرف على ثقافات مختلفه
جعلها تجول مناطق وبلدان مختلفه على
درجاتها الناريه الرحاله السعوديه امل
احمد وزوجها يا جولان في العديد من
المناطق داخل السعوديه وخارجها اليوم
سنتعرف على ترحالهما وتفاصيل اكثر في هذا
التقرير
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
جمعهما شغف الترحال بالدراجه الناريه
الرحاله السعوديه امل احمد وزوجها الهندي
مير شكيل يجوبان مناطق السعوديه وخارجها
بحثا عن المتعه واشباع شغفهما بالسفر
والترحال
انا وزوجي زوجي بيعمل غير ناطقين باللغه
العربيه اللغه اللي هي الاردن تم دعوته
احد الفرق لانه يجوا يعملوا المحاضره وانا
كنت اعمل في هذه الشركه بعد كده الحمد لله
يعني تم التعارف ومن يوم ما يعني صرنا تحت
سقف واحد زي ما يقولوا يعني صار يطلع هو
لوحده بس يشجعني اكثر اني اطلع معه رحله
ولا رحله شويه شيده جوه جده كده لفات
خفيفه بعد كذا قال لي يلا نطلع خلاص نطلع
رايد رايد طويل فابتدينا خلص من بعدها
ابتدى عندي يمكن الحب انه كل ما سمعت انه
في تجمع اقول له يلا
جالت الرحاله امل مع زوجها اماكن متعدده
داخل السعوديه وخارجها ومنها جبال
الهيمالايا حيث حققت لقب اول السعوديه
تعبر اعلى ممر مركبات في العالم والذي
يصنف من اصعب الطرق نظرا لطبيعته الوعيره
وكثره الجليد فيه زرنا اماكن كثيره داخل
المملكه روحنا الجنوب رحنا الشرقيه الرياض
وطبعا القريبه
مكه
اخر رحله حائل في خارجيا طلعنا الامارات
طلعنا
يعني نقول اطول رحله لينا كانت لها ملايط
لان جبلها ملايا كابتن عامر
يعني هي موجود معي انا ما يفكر ولا شيء
اول اول لما هي ارك دباب كان شويه خوف لكن
بعد ما سويته رحله خلاص هي هي افضل سياره
تسعى الرحاله امل التي لا زالت تتدرب على
اتقان قياده الدراجه الناريه بقياده
دراجتها الخاصه لتحقيق شغفها بالترحال
ونشر ثقافات بلدها والتعرف على ثقافات
المجتمعات الاخرى انا اقول للبنات ابداوا
قياده ركوب الدراجات البنات سهله ما اظن
انها فيها صعوبه
[موسيقى]
لصباح العربيه حنان بخاري جده